queridos amigos de visualpolitik menudas
se está liando en África El golpe de
estado en níger significa mucho más que
la típica toma del poder por parte del
ejército sí es verdad que níger es uno
de los países más pobres del mundo pero
pese a ello tenía una democracia
reconocida tenía un gobierno dispuesto a
pedir ayuda internacional para frenar a
un yihadismo que está haciendo del
sahell su territorio en este sentido
Niger era el gran Aliado de occidente en
el corazón del sahel sin embargo ahora
todo esto ha saltado por los aires con
el golpe de estado de finales de Julio
ahora la junta militar de níger sigue
buscando ayuda extranjera Pero quiere
cambiar de aliados la junta de niger
pide ayuda al grupo ruso va a generar
ante la amenaza de una intervención
militar pero esperad un momento porque
la intervención militar no la puso sobre
la mesa ninguna Potencia de occidente
molesta por la creciente influencia del
kremlin en África al menos no
directamente
ha sido la cdao la comunidad económica
de Estados de África occidental la que
no está dispuesta a tolerar otro golpe
militar y reclama que regrese al poder
Mohamed bazum el presidente de puesto de
níger Y eso es exactamente lo que ha
hecho que suenen tambores de guerra en
África 10 de agosto 2023 los líderes de
África occidental organizan una fuerza
de reserva para responder al golpe de
estado níger y lo peor de todo es que
esta intervención militar podría ir más
allá de níger y desencadenar un
conflicto regional que termine
extendiéndose por múltiples países así
hablaba el portavoz de la junta militar
el coronel amado abdumen
partículas
eh les pasa
no ha dudado en acusar a una extranjera
de instigar y preparar un ataque contra
níger por supuesto se refiere a Francia
su antigua metrópoli de hecho la junta
militar ha roto todos los acuerdos
militares de níger con Francia el
gobierno de macrón se limitó a indicar
que apoya la intervención de la cda por
lo tanto ya estáis viendo cómo se están
poniendo las cosas así que os estaréis
preguntando por qué se ha producido este
golpe de estado en níger qué papel juega
Rusia en todo esto y sobre todo A
cuántos países puede terminar salpicando
este conflicto en visualpolitik hoy
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
última democracia del sahel
el sahel es una estrecha franja de
tierra al sur del desierto del Sahara
caracterizada por su altísima pobreza en
el centro del sahell se sitúan cuatro
países de oeste a este Mali burkina faso
níger y Chad Pues bien todos ellos
tienen varias cosas en común para
empezar ninguno de estos países tiene
salida al mar además en los cuatro se
habla francés Con lo que ya sabéis Cuál
era la potencia colonial Asimismo son
mayoritariamente de religión musulmana y
ahora También tienen otra cosa en común
en todos ellos ya gobiernan los
militares después del golpe de estado
que ha puesto punto final a la séptima
República de níger Y sí más de uno
estará pensando pero a ver Alberto si
Niger consiguió la independencia de
Francia en 1960 63 años y siete
repúblicas sale a 9 años Por República
Pues sí pero es que esta habilidad y
níger son dos palabras que no suelen ir
de la mano
no obstante todo parece haber cambiado a
partir del año 2010 un golpe militar a
favor de la Democracia desalojo del
poder al presidente mamado utanya un
hombre que había sido elegido las urnas
pero que aspiraba perpetuarse en el
poder y convertir a níger en un régimen
autoritario la transición contó con el
acompañamiento de la comunidad
internacional y dio lugar a la
Constitución de la séptima República un
periodo que en 2021 pudo ver el primer
traspaso Pacífico de poderes entre
presidentes
sin embargo amigos el sahell ha visto en
la última década como una grave amenaza
desestabilizaba toda la región estamos
hablando del yihadismo el fanatismo
religioso encuentra sus soldados entre
los desesperados y muchas veces
hambrientos habitantes de estos países
del sahel son personas que han nacido en
uno de los peores lugares del mundo y
los yihadistas les prometen un presente
mejor y un futuro en el paraíso y claro
el problema es que la alternativa es la
agricultura de subsistencia de la que en
níger malvive más del 80% de la
población de hecho la pobreza extrema
alcanza a casi la mitad de todos los
habitantes del país son cifras que en
los 13 años de la séptima República
apenas se han podido revertir hablamos
de datos muy similares a los de países
vecinos como Mali Y burkina faso ambos
han tenido golpes de estado en los
últimos tres años que acabaron con la
democracia Mali en 2021 y burkina faso
en 2022 en ambos casos los militares
tomaron el poder con el pretexto de
acabar con el yihadismo sin embargo
amigos han conseguido todo lo contrario
Mirad este mapa elaborado por la empresa
estadounidense stratford sobre
incidentes violentos en el sahel entre
agosto de 2021 y agosto de 2022
[Música]
la guerra contra el yihadismo ha
disparado la violencia en 2022 las
muertes por el yihadismo en el sahel
aumentaron un 75%, a más de 10.000 el
caos se impone y la junta militar de
Mali ha recurrido a los Wagner en
burkina faso el gobierno apenas controla
el 40% del país en níger la situación no
es tan extrema pero también actúan los
mismos grupos yihadistas que asolan Mali
y burkina faso hablamos de filiales de
alta edad y del daes Asimismo sufre
constantes ataques de poco jaram y del
estado islámico en su zona fronteriza
con Nigeria Sin embargo a diferencia de
lo que pasa en burkina faso y en Mali el
último año en níger estaba siendo el
menos mortífero desde el 2018 y cuál es
la razón para que exista esta diferencia
pues ni más ni menos que el enfoque
adoptado en níger por el gobierno de
Mohamed bazum contra el yihadismo su
estrategia tiene varias patas primero la
ayuda militar mental fundamentalmente la
prestada por Francia y Estados Unidos
segundo la mejora de los servicios del
estado en las áreas más deprimidas y
tercero otras iniciativas que son tan
opuestas a la guerra contra el yihadismo
como evidentemente polémicas
terroristas para abrir el diálogo el
plan de desmovilización respaldado por
bazum prometió reintegrar en la sociedad
a los yihadistas que te pusieran las
armas nada más diálogo a cambio de una
tregua libertad a cambio de la paz desde
el punto de vista occidental conversar
con los terroristas es mala idea implica
acceder a sus chantajes y abra la puerta
a que se produzcan nuevos ataques para
lograr nuevas sesiones
sin embargo en un país como níger hay
que poner en una balanza el poder real
que tiene el estado y las fuerzas de los
grupos terroristas si la lucha está
equilibrada ir a la guerra puede ser
todo un desastre para la población hay
explorar otras vías Y claro hay quien no
está dispuesto a tolerar la más mínima
señal de debilidad así se pronunciaba el
nuevo presidente de níger El general
Omar chiani al justificar su golpe de
estado por el supuesto deterioro de la
seguridad provocado por el yihadismo no
amplio
a la dispersión progresiva y Inevitable
de un otro Esta es la misma excusa que
los golpistas dieron en Mali y en
burkina faso pero amigos ya habéis visto
que los datos de níger son bastante
diferentes así que algo más tiene que
haber La pregunta es el qué pues
posiblemente sean ciertos los rumores
previos al golpe de que el general
chiani iba a ser destituido como el jefe
de la guardia presidencial no perdáis de
vista que es la guardia presidencial la
que da el golpe tomando como rehén al
presidente bazum el ejército tuvo que
pronunciarse después Mirad el ejército
de níger respalda El golpe contra el
occidental para evitar un baño de sangre
Pero bueno tampoco merece la pena darle
muchas más vueltas a todo esto Al fin y
al cabo son militares dando un golpe de
estado para hacerse por el poder sea por
ambición personal o por descontento
nacional por una razón o por otra es el
pan nuestro de cada día en el continente
africano sin embargo amigos esta vez se
han topado con el rechazo frontal de una
organización regional como la cdao una
organización que parece dispuesta a todo
con tal de restaurar la democracia en
níger y mucho ojo que no sería la
primera vez
[Música]
Ecos de guerra
te asediado es una organización
integrada por 15 países de África
occidental entre los que se encuentra
níger en un principio se trataba de una
organización con un propósito económico
al formar un único bloque comercial pero
esperad un momento amigos Porque la cede
ao también ha movilizado fuerzas de paz
en la región e intervino en países
miembros en momentos de Gran
inestabilidad en los últimos 30 años han
actuado en Sierra Leona viene avisao
Costa de Marfil Liberia Mali y gambio
[Música]
la última intervención militar de la cda
O fue en 2017 en gambia allí después de
dos décadas en el poder ya yamé se
resistía a abandonar el timón de Mando y
cedérselo a dama barrow que había ganado
las elecciones presidenciales la cedeó
entonces formó una coalición de tropas
de senegal gana y Nigeria y se dispuso a
invadir gambia al final ya ya me
renunció a los tres días y la democracia
fue restaurada
sin embargo amigos níger no es gambia su
territorio es 100 veces más grande y su
ejército además de ser más numeroso
cuenta con años de entrenamiento por
parte de fuerzas occidentales Así que la
intervención militar es compleja y
supondría asumir muchos más riesgos el
primero el de la propia vida del
presidente basum que no está en el
exilio sino en manos de los golpistas
funcionarios occidentales la junta de
níger advirtió de que mataría al
presidente de puestos y se produjese una
intervención militar además seguro que
muchos os estaréis preguntando por qué
la cdao se ha mostrado ahora tan firme Y
tajante ante níger cuando recientemente
también hubo golpes de estado similares
en Mali y burkina faso
pues bien la clave de todo la tiene una
persona
volatinubu es el nuevo presidente de
Nigeria desde el pasado mayo y no hubo
ha tenido el tiempo suficiente para que
a principios de Julio le nombraran
presidente de la cdao un cargo
representativo desde el este mensaje en
su toma de Posesión
en su discurso también defendió la
democracia la libertad y el estado de
derecho y todo esto son mucho más que
las palabras de volatinuo son la carta
de presentación del nuevo presidente de
Nigeria ante la cedeao ante el
continente africano e incluso ante el
mundo entero
Al fin y al cabo no podemos olvidar el
enorme peso que tiene Nigeria hablamos
de la gran potencia africana junto a
Egipto y Sudáfrica Y por supuesto es
quien lleva la voz cantante de la cdao
al margen de su preocupación porque
níger corra la misma suerte de Mali y
burkina faso y se dispare la violencia
en la zona Nigeria quiere asumir su
papel de líder regional y claro el golpe
de níger tuvo lugar apenas tres semanas
después del discurso de Así que mientras
la diplomacia siga Sin dar resultados
los preparativos militares seguirán su
curso la credibilidad de volatinuo está
en juego el contingente de la cda O para
la invasión de niger pueda ascender a
25.000 efectivos más de la mitad del
contingente sería portado por Nigeria
por su parte también han confirmado que
enviarán tropas senegal Costa de Marfil
y benín y luego hay otros dos países con
efectivo sobre el terreno uno es Francia
la antigua potencia colonial está siendo
utilizada por los golpistas como El
Chivo expia todo lo malo de níger es
culpa de Francia y de hecho los
golpistas han atacado su embajada
incluso acusaron al gobierno de macron
de liberar terroristas Es más no
queremos Mostrar imágenes desagradables
pero los golpistas llenaron un estadio
de fútbol y la gente lesbitoreaba
mientras decapitaban un gallo pintado
con la bandera de Francia seguro que con
todo esto ya os hacéis una idea el
rechazo que tienen hacia Francia
Pues bien Los Galos mantienen allí una
base permanente equipada con aviones de
combate drones reaper y 1500 soldados el
gobierno de macron ha dicho que apoya
los esfuerzos de la cdao para devolver
el poder a bazum ahora bien Lo más
probable es que no se mueva ni un
soldado francés no sea que la junta
militar haya llegado para quedarse y le
dé por revisar acuerdos como el del
pasado mayo 5 de mayo de 2023 níger
acuerdo firmado con la profesora no para
la explotación de yacimiento de uranio
hasta el año 2040 está claro que el
interés de Francia es continuar
explotando el uranio de níger que ha
sido su tercer mayor proveedor durante
las últimas décadas luego el otro país
que tiene tropas en níger es Estados
Unidos en total son más de 1000
efectivos desplegados en varias bases de
drones de momento la Casa Blanca está
apostando por la vía diplomática pero le
están pidiendo pasar a la acción el
líder dice que es un rey en insta
Estados Unidos a detener el golpe el
expresidente lo pidió Ni más ni menos
que en una carta al Sí parece difícil de
entender Qué clase de golpistas dejan
que su prisionero se comunique
libremente con el exterior Porque
después del golpe bazum puso un tweet e
incluso ha hablado por teléfono con
blinken con Sam's Michelle con borrell
vamos que solo le faltó hacerse youtuber
ahora bien ni la Casa Blanca ni la Unión
Europea están consiguiendo avances en
las negociaciones con la junta militar
de níger los golpistas han rechazado
incluso recibir una delegación
tripartita compuesta por representantes
de la cdao la unión africana y la ONU y
es que sabéis que los militares tienen
muy claro cuál quieren que sea en lugar
de origen en el mundo y sus aliados
atentos
[Música]
Más allá del muro
las juntas militares de Mali burkina
faso nos ofrecen la hoja de ruta a
seguir por el golpista africano moderno
lo primero es atacar a la antigua
potencia colonial por todas las vías
posibles Ellos tienen que tener la culpa
de todo en el caso de níger sin ir más
lejos ya os hemos mostrado algún ejemplo
pero esperad un momento porque todavía
pueden hacer más contra Francia en Mali
por ejemplo eliminaron el francés como
lengua oficial Y en este país y en
burkina faso echaron a todas las tropas
francesas que estaban allí combatiendo
el yihadismo casi nada sea como sea el
siguiente paso sería tomar posiciones
Dentro de este mundo multipolar y en
níger ya han elegido los sastres de
níger se apresuran a fabricar banderas
rusas tras el golpe los golpistas han
creado en África una franja de países
dirigidos por militares que se extiende
desde el Océano Atlántico hasta el mar
rojo la mayoría de estos países están
ahora más alineados con Rusia que con
occidente Y no sólo eso sino que
pretenden levantar un muro frente al
antaño indiscutible influencia
occidental amigos ni Rusia ni Wagner
están involucrados en los preparativos
del golpe de estado de níger pero una
vez que este Se ha producido ambos están
dispuestos a sacar provecho Wagner se
propaga por África como si de un virus
se tratara
antes del motín de pigosing Los
mercenarios del grupo Wagner formaban
parte del catálogo de servicios
ofrecidos por Rusia en sus negociaciones
diplomáticas de este modo es como Wagner
llegó a países como la República
centroafricana o Mali donde los
regímenes autoritarios contratan a los
hombres de prigo sin para hacer el
trabajo sucio Mientras tanto el kremlin
desplaza occidente como la potencia
influyente en la zona
Putin está muy interesado en África tal
y como se ha escenificado en la Cumbre
que se acaba de celebrar en San
Petersburgo así que todo indica que
brigotzin seguirá adelante con sus
operaciones en el continente africano
mientras siga resultando útil a los
propósitos de Putin y ya visteis al
principio del vídeo que la junta militar
de níger ha pedido ayuda al grupo Wagner
un grupo que en República centroafricana
en Mali en Sudán Allí se han hecho con
el control de las minas de oro y de
diamantes que tiene níger para Wagner
pues fundamentalmente uranio privar
Europa del uranio nigerino dibujaría una
sonrisa en los rostros de Putin y
brigotching pero no parece demasiado
atractivo para Los mercenarios rusos se
necesita algo más y bueno níger cuenta
con alguna que otra mina de oro y
también tiene petróleo de hecho níger
aspiraba este año a multiplicar por 5 su
Modesta producción de crudo El caso es
que como bien sabéis los que sois
habituales de visualpolitik Wagner
siempre saca tajada aún así Esta es la
menor de las preocupaciones de la junta
militar la intervención de la cdao es su
prioridad número uno y todo apunta a que
en caso de producirse Finalmente la
intervención los golpistas de níger no
estarían solos
burkinali dicen que la intervención
militar en níger sería una declaración
de guerra el Muro de los golpistas se
está fortificando y mucho ojo porque
Argelia y Guinea también han mostrado su
rechazo a la intervención militar
Mientras tanto la cdao continúa
presionando a la junta militar de cherni
al ordenar la movilización de su fuerza
de reserva para restablecer el orden
constitucional en níger este conflicto
amenaza con involucrar directamente a un
montón de países africanos que ya han
dicho que tomarán las armas para
defender sus posiciones en visualpolitik
Seguiremos muy atentos a este conflicto
incipiente pero ahora la pregunta es
para ti crees que la cdao conseguirá
restaurar la democracia en níger se
involucrará directamente alguna potencia
ajena al continente africano déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios si te ha
resultado interesante el vídeo Dale al
botón de like y compártelo con tus
amigos Un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]